[Music]
each day in the united states over 120
people die from an opioid overdose
many of these deaths are preventable
in fact when someone nearby is
experiencing an overdose your awareness
and action can save their life
but what are opioids how can you
recognize an overdose and how can you
effectively intervene
people have been using opioids for
thousands of years
some of the first opioids opium morphine
and codeine
came from the resin of the opium poppy
more recently a variety of opioid drugs
have been manufactured for medical use
their names may sound familiar
percocet vicodin and fentanyl are a few
our bodies naturally produce opioid-like
substances which bind to receptors in
the brain spinal cord and other parts of
the body resulting in pain relief and
feelings of euphoria
when a person takes opioids they also
bind to these receptors
intensifying these responses
unfortunately using opioids can cause
dependence or addiction where
increasingly large doses are needed to
create the same effects
in large doses opioids can dangerously
depress awareness and breathing and may
lead to permanent injury or death
an opioid overdose usually occurs
accidentally
when the amount of opioids taken
overwhelms the body and sometimes when
opioid effects combine with other
substances that impair awareness and
breathing like alcohol
the likelihood of an overdose does not
discriminate by age gender race or
religion
anyone could suffer from an overdose
even a member of your family or
community
luckily you can help simply by
recognizing the signs of an overdose
it's as easy as abc
a awareness
opioids affect people's awareness by
attaching to receptors in the brain that
keep us alert
a person experiencing an overdose may
appear dazed drowsy or unconscious
you may also notice they have pinpoint
pupils
b
breathing
opioids also act on brain regions
responsible for breathing
an opioid overdose may cause a person to
breathe very slowly
gurgle due to a blockage in the airway
or stop breathing altogether
c
color
the lips and fingertips of someone
experiencing an opioid overdose may be
pale ashen purple or blue because
opioids can deprive the body of oxygen
once you've recognized the signs of an
opioid overdose it's time to act here
are the steps needed to save a life
one assess awareness
talk loudly
shout and give a chest noogie by
pressing your knuckles into the sternum
of the affected individual
to try to get them to respond
2. not responding
then call 9-1-1 and notify those nearby
of the situation
3.
if you're suspecting an overdose
administer naloxone to knock these
opioids off their receptors
this will restore consciousness and
breathing and oxygen can once again
travel throughout the body
if the person is having another medical
emergency such as a stroke or heart
attack naloxone won't hurt them because
it specifically works on opioid
receptors and you've called 9-1-1 so
help for other emergencies is on its way
four restore breathing while waiting for
naloxone to work and help to arrive
open the person's airway and place them
in the recovery position so they can
breathe easier and to prevent them from
choking on their tongue or vomit
if you're comfortable you can give them
rescue breaths
if you know basic life support use those
skills now to determine if chest
compressions and aed are needed
five finally stay with the person until
the ambulance arrives
while you wait for the ambulance you may
have to administer a second dose of
naloxone
you should do this if after a few
minutes the person is still not
responsive or they show signs of their
overdose returning
make sure they get to the hospital for
further observation since overdose may
come back if the naloxone wears off
the keys to saving someone from an
opioid overdose are
first suspected when you see that
awareness breathing and color are
impaired
even without naloxone you can call 9-1-1
ask for help assess awareness and
support breathing
you will be most effective if you carry
naloxone everywhere you go and become
aware of community-placed naloxone in
locations like lobbies or near
defibrillators and fire extinguishers
you can obtain your own naloxone from a
medical provider pharmacist local harm
reduction group or community access
naloxone rescue boxes like nalox boxes
share this video now so others can be
aware and prepared to respond to an
opioid overdose
[Music]
you